[Applaudissements]
j'aime beaucoup parler français je
m'appelle mao prêcha mal et je suis en
danger ou en quatre ans mais je parle
bas bien parce que les difficiles
maintenant je comprends en bois qu'est
ce qui vous a décidé à vous inscrire à
l'école toth parce que je besoin de la
langue française
parce que maintenant je suis en france
qu'est avant je parle pas français
maintenant je parle prendre un pot et
maintenant je suis content parce que je
n'ai pas besoin de traducteur
est ce que vous vous souvenez du premier
mot que vous avez appris en français je
prends mes mots c'est merci beaucoup
quatre mois plus tôt chamali ne parlait
pas français
je les ai rencontrés en septembre 2015 à
paris dans un lycée désaffecté où
s'étaient installés des migrants c'était
un demandeur d'asile afghan parmi tant
d'autres je me souviens qui dessinait le
drapeau afghan
sur ce tableau d'une ancienne salle de
classe il était incapable de s'exprimer
en français
alors je savais rien de lui après seize
semaines de formation chez toth
il est capable maintenant de communiquer
en français et donc il est autonome dans
ses démarches administratives et dans sa
vie quotidienne continue de dessiner
il a d'ailleurs fait ceux des simples
pour son professeur à tôtes aujourd'hui
je peux dire que je sais qu'il est est
alors par qui il est je vais pas dire
que je connais sa situation
administrative son histoire ses origines
etc
non je sais qu'il est parce que mais je
connais son caractère je connais
certains de ses goûts on discute on
n'est pas d'accord sur tout enfin bref
il est devenu chamali un être à part
entière et un ami
je vous parle de chamailler aujourd'hui
pour illustrer mon propos
nous devons créer une cohésion avec les
personnes exilées et cette cohésion
commence par la communication et par les
changes
quand les migrants arrivent en france
sont considérés comme un groupe de
personnes identique
la preuve on les appelle migrants
réfugiés exilés maladroitement sa jamais
trop savoir quel est le terme le plus
approprié
et puis après la première rencontre se
précise on les appelle les soudanais les
syriens les afghans mais ce n'est qu'en
passant par la communication et par les
changes qu'on peut se rencontrer qu'on
peut partager nos avis c'est en
discutant avec une personne que
finalement on se fait son propre avis
sur cette personne là on sort de la
stigmatisation
[Musique]
comment vivre ensemble si on se parle
pas comment partager nos valeurs
respectives nos codes nos émotions sans
la parole c'est pour ça qu'on a créés
thot transmettre un horizon à tous au
top
c'est une école de français diplômante
pour les réfugiés demandeurs d'asile non
titulaires d'un diplôme dans leur pays
aujourd'hui je consacre tout mon temps
au développement note le concept c'est
une école qui a qui prouve qu'ils leur
proposent des conditions d'apprentissage
stable ça paraît simple 1 mais 160
heures de cours dispensés par un
professeur qualifié rémunérés toujours
dans la même salle toujours le même
professeur toujours les mêmes horaires
et toujours la même classe les
conditions d'apprentissage spécifiques
avec des ateliers d'insertion
professionnelle d un soutien social un
soutien psychologique des conseils
juridiques
on les aide dans tous dans tous leurs
besoins pour les aider à trouver leur
place ici en france
et des conditions d'apprentissage varié
avec justement des ateliers de création
avec du théâtre du chant du dessin et
aussi des sorties conviviales
pendant ces sorties pendant ces ateliers
en fait on crée du lien et en fait on
s'aime tous à tôtes toutes nationalités
confondues leur permettent de faire ses
ateliers ses sorties ça leur permet de
s'approprier la langue française dans
plusieurs contextes on appartient tous
un gros l'école toth a ouvert en juin
dernier grâce à une campagne de
financement participatif
on a récolté près de soixante six mille
euros
en quarante jours auprès de 1000 153
personnes
ça nous a permis d'accueillir 44
personnes dans l'école toth
cette première session s'est terminée là
en octobre avec l'examen et donc il ya
eu un taux de réussite à l'examen de 93%
[Musique]
toutes ces personnes ont donc un diplôme
d'état reconnu internationalement grâce
à des subventions et à des dons qui
continuent d'arriver
il ya dix jours on lançait la deuxième
promotion de tôtes avec cette fois-ci 70
personnes on a quasiment doublé nos
effectifs
alors voilà tout ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est incroyable on est extrêmement
fier plus motivé que jamais et y a pas
que ça chacun des étudiants de la 1ère
session
c'est devenu un être à part entière à
nos yeux mais aussi chaque membre de
l'équipe de toth est devenu un individu
à part entière à leurs yeux
également ils ont retrouvé leur identité
cette identité il n'était plus capable
de présenter cette identité dans cette
nouvelle langue qu'il ne connaissait pas
je pourrais vous raconter l'histoire de
chacun d'entre eux puisque toutes ces
histoires sont courageuses belle et
forte
moussa et younes par exemple en juin
dernier il n'avait jamais tenu un stylo
de leur vie ni un cahier rien
aujourd'hui ils remplissent les pages de
leurs cahiers et ils ont obtenu plus de
75% à l'examen voilà toutes ces
histoires sur les suds d'un travail et
d'une motivation intense de leur part et
de notre part toutes ces personnes se
sont rencontrés sont parlés on travaille
et ça c'est sûr et on réussit alors
peut-être que vous vous dites moi aussi
j'ai envie de participer à cette
démarche et par où commencer
mais déjà en étant convaincu que c'est
la bonne démarche
après je vous rassure un mois je me suis
pas réveillé un matin en disant pop je
plaque tout je crée une école tout va
bien non non moi j'étais ingénieur
télécom depuis 2012 à paris et puis bon
je trouvais que mon métier manqué un
petit peu de d'humains c'était ce que je
cherchais alors j'étais un peu perdu je
me disais je vais partir en asie
travaille dans une ong
puis j'ai un ami qui m'a dit mais tu
sais et louise a pas besoin d'aller à
l'autre bout du monde pour faire de
l'humanitaire
il ya des gens à aider ici à paris bah
ouais c'était évident alors du coup j'ai
été bénévole pendant plusieurs années
principalement dans l'enseignement du
français et j'étais aux premières loges
pour constater qu' il y avait ce besoin
constant et grandissant des des migrants
en général d'apprendre le français et je
voyais bien que moi ce que je leur
composaient ça répondait que
partiellement à leurs besoins alors avec
deux filles extraordinaire face fin en
je me suis lancé
et après bon certes plusieurs mois de
travail intense si aujourd'hui contourna
trice de cette école je suis entouré
d'une équipe de maintenant plus de vingt
personnes plus que génial
alors je suis pas venu ici aujourd'hui
pour vous demander fait la même chose
que moi pour vous conseiller de faire la
même chose que moi mais je suis venu ici
parce que nous devons être les acteurs
de cette société impliquons nous vous
donnons l'opportunité aux exilés de
s'inclure en france socialement et
économiquement
rétablissons l'ordre en faisant société
autour de ce même langage
donnons-leur l'opportunité de parler
français pour pouvoir échanger et
partager transmettre nos connaissances
mutuellement on a tous quelque chose à
sa portée khalil par exemple nous a
apporté sa joie de vivre sa bonne humeur
et sa motivation à toute épreuve
il a 18 ans il est arrivé en france en
tant que mineur isolé a dormi pendant
plusieurs semaines à la rue et a
finalement été accueilli dans une
famille française
[Musique]
il fait partie des élèves les plus
motivés notre session il est venu à tous
les cours à tous les ateliers théâtre
je me souviens pendant les ateliers
théâtre il me disait au moins pendant
quelques heures je peux être quelqu'un
d'autre ça me fait du bien
voilà il fait partie de ceux qui ont
également qu' on est les meilleurs
résultats à l'examen et je me
souviendrai toujours de son expression
en sortant de l'examen jeudi alors
khalil comment ça s'est passé
il est ouvert les bras elle a dit
c'était magnifique
c'est dur d'apprendre le français non
c'est pas très dur si toi aussi tu dis
que je vais apprendre le français
c'est c'est facile je sûr que je parle
comme les comme les joueurs français
c'est comme une langue de ma mère pour
moi j'ai envie d'apprendre plus court
des dessins un cours des ateliers de
théâtre cours de change pour apprendre
la culture français bon j'aime bien le
espoirs de français c'est comme
l'histoire de victor hogo mais je vais
prendre l'air tous les stades de france
et je suis là maintenant
la vie c'est une chance pour nous je
vais faire un comédien vraiment très
bien ces temps de rire maintenant c'est
le temps de rire maintenant sont les
mots de rallye je remercie
[Applaudissements]